time now on the show where we talk about
the things we can't wait to see and
there are plenty of things we can't wait
to see this weekend a great slate of
games as previously mentioned shireen
as always you get to go first what is
the first thing you can't wait to see
come sunday i want to see if brian
flores and you alluded to it
can he slow down that chief's offense
they're not going to stop it he knows
that because they're not going to get to
use 14 defenders they're only going to
have 11 out there
the dolphins defense has been very good
this year they're second
in scoring defense but the chiefs are
second in scoring offense so it's a
classic battle
but you talked about flores with the
patriots he was the defensive
coordinator
beat the chiefs twice that season 43 to
40 in the regular season and 37-31 in
the afc championship game in overtime
high scoring games so i think as you
said earlier the dolphins are going to
have to score a lot of points in that
game to keep up with the chiefs and i
think that's going to be very difficult
but either that or the dolphins are
going to have to force some turnovers
but it's it's a very
interesting i think matchup between that
chief's offense and that dolphins
defense
yeah and i don't know that the dolphins
have the offense to
outscore the kansas city offense
especially in light of a very balanced
kansas city defense we saw a couple of
interceptions from tyron matthew
when the chiefs beat the broncos on
sunday night they can slow down the run
they can slow down the pass and i just
don't think
that the dolphins offense is prolific
enough to match
whatever it is that the dolphins defense
can hold the chief's offense to
first one for me can the minnesota
vikings who will be going into a hot
environment in tampa bay probably being
required to wear their purple jerseys to
soak up the rays of the sun it's going
to be sunny it's going to be 80 degrees
the buccaneers coming off of a bye week
the vikings have never beaten tom brady
and the vikings i don't think match up
very well
with the tampa bay buccaneers offense
but the season is on the line this is a
de facto playoff game for the vikings
they're six and six they lose this one
they're done and this is their
opportunity to leapfrog the buccaneers
for the sixth seed at least for now
because the bucks are seven and five a
vikings win would
would make both of them seven and six
and give minnesota the tiebreaker but
between the receivers that tom brady has
at his disposal the
overmatch secondary the vikings have
specifically at corner and the inability
to put heat
up the middle that's how you you harass
and harangue tom brady is with heat up
the middle
it's going to be hard to do and it's a
tall order i want to see if the vikings
can at least keep it close keep it
interesting
they need their run game to fire on all
cylinders
the tampa bay rush defense however is
pretty good this one to me could get
ugly
quickly and the buccaneers need a
resounding win to get that
that magic back that they had before
they lost three of their last four games
shireen
they're making a stretch run where they
need to win they need to get to the
playoffs
they need to vindicate everything
they've done this year to go all in with
tom brady
and uh we're going to find out whether
or not they're ready to make a big push
come sunday afternoon yeah mike zimmer's
done it before mike in 2013 he was the
bengals defensive coordinator
when they had tom brady had his one of
his worst games ever so he's done it
before and
and this defense has had some injuries
we know it's going to be tough
mike evans is going to play despite that
hamstring injury and they need to get
the ball to mike evans more than what
they have he has been good in the red
zone
but yeah and to me it's an interesting
matchup as you said because the vikings
need to win to stay
in that playoff hunt every loss now is
just so
magnified for those teams that are
fighting for those last couple of wild
card spots
were you covering the buccaneers in 98
yes 99 was my last season
1998 was when randy moss was a rookie
the only loss for the vikings that year
was at tampa bay i guess there would be
some poetry to it if justin jefferson
who is
as spectacular not without the
touchdowns but from the yardage
standpoint as moss was
if they could reverse that this year
would be a huge win for the vikings i
don't think they can pull it off but
we'll see what happens all right what's
next on your list
my list is andy dalton returns to
cincinnati and i want to see how
the few fans are that are there and how
the team
really honors andy dalton because he was
very good for them you know he showed up
after the
carson palmer has retired and retired
traded all of that happened
and he led him to the playoffs five
times in his first five season and
that's
significant in cincinnati we know their
history of not making the playoffs we
know what they've been
since then he was very good in
cincinnati in those first five seasons
so
i have a feeling that they'll honor him
very well and this wasn't supposed to be
a game that he was going to play it was
supposed to be joe burrow versus dak
prescott
both of those quarterbacks are out for
the season so now we have brandon allen
versus andy dalton
the only reason to watch this game is
the pre-game just to see how that goes
with andy dalton after that
i don't know if there's much reason to
turn on this game mike
three and nine versus two nine and one
both teams playing for pride
or draft positioning and frankly at this
point go with the draft positioning
don't try to win these games get a
higher spot in the draft order and get a
better player
to try to make your bad team better as
quickly as possible i'm looking at
another quarterback potential revenge
game although it's been a while since
alex smith last played for the 49ers
that was the team that drafted him back
in 2005. he was there
through 2012. it seemed like he had a
different offensive coordinator
every year he finally hit his stride in
2011
took the 49ers to the nfc championship
game and then
suffered a concussion in 2012 you're not
supposed to lose
your job via an injury but that's how he
lost a job colin kaepernick came in and
kaepernick grabbed the job and they
traded alex smith to the chiefs after
that
and now alex smith gets a chance to go
to a stadium where he never played when
he was with the 49ers but still it's at
the 49ers
and it's an impactful game this is
another one of those games where
if you would look at just the game
without
any understanding of the broader
circumstances you can see five and seven
49ers five and seven washington you say
who cares
well this is the opportunity for the
49ers to make a late kick and maybe
steal a playoff spot
and washington tied for first place in
the nfc east this is a sneaky great game
and alex smith has been spectacular
someone suggested to me today
not only should he win the comeback
player of the ward unanimously shireen
they should name it after him and i kind
of like that
yeah it's not a bad idea mike for what
he's come back from 17 surgeries nearly
lost his life nearly lost his leg and
now here he is doing what he's doing for
washing again
and you know he's not just winning the
award for for coming back and stepping
onto the field
i mean he's playing at a high level he
had back-to-back 300-yard games he had
never done that in his career had a
career-high passing yards i think it was
389 it was just
under 400 this year he's been very good
for washington i know you're looking at
stats you go i ain't had four touchdowns
five interceptions and
not that good but he just seems to be
getting better and
you know he didn't miss a whole entire
season and came back and and i just
think every week he gets better that
running game certainly has helped
with antonio gibson and the other guys
they have had there running the football
and i know gibson's banged up right now
but they have been very good on offense
since he's been in there and i do think
he should be their quarterback of the
future i think they found that guy in
alex smith if he wants to continue to
play after this season but
you go back to when they first drafted
him mike in san francisco they had their
choice aaron rodgers or alex smith
and they chose alex smith and it's hard
to believe that it's been
14 seasons that he's been in this league
and it certainly hasn't been aaron
rodgers
but he's been a very good quarterback in
his career since he left san francisco
yeah he's been spectacular overall and
uh
relative to plenty of other quarterbacks
who have come and gone since 2005 and
the comeback that we saw the resilience
overcoming the adversity we've never
seen anything like it in sports not just
football but in any sport all right one
more shireen
what are you looking forward to seeing
on sunday
well mike last week we wanted to see if
the browns could beat a team with the
winning record they
did that against the titans look very
good and now they have
a chance to enact revenge against the
baltimore ravens who they lost to 38-9
38-6 in the season opener their worst
loss this season we thought they were
going to be the same old browns
they're not the same old browns and you
know what i think
we have i think their offense has proved
us right mike that they are a better
offense without
odell beckham in it four touchdown
passes from baker mayfield last week
they all went to different receivers
nine different receivers caught passes
not counting baker midfield's catch
they've been very good without odell
beckham on offense
yeah it's run the ball and use that
running game to set up the passing game
the key though is
the pass rush the titans didn't have a
great when it made it easier for baker
mayfield what will the ravens do by way
of bringing heat on baker mayfield and
will he have a game
like he did on sunday or will it be a
lot worse than that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports